ALEX DANILO: Hello everybody.
It's great to be here in
the smartphone capital
of the world.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX DANILO: Of course
it's a very exciting time
for us with Chrome to come
and visit you and talk
about HTML and web
technologies today.
My name is Alex Danilo.
My colleague Eiji couldn't
come here today, unfortunately.
You can follow me on Google+ or
Twitter or anywhere on the web.
Today I would like to talk
about the future of mobile HTML
and web technologies.
We're going to have a whole
lot of different slides.
Each slide will cover
a different aspect
of mobile APIs, and
there's a little guide here
with a color-coding.
This color-coding tells you
if the feature is ready,
or if the feature
is coming soon,
or if it's in the
long distance horizon.
And we also have per-browser
color-coding, as well.
Before I start with that, I'd
like to show you a website
that you should all go to.
This website is
chromestatus.com.
Chromestatus.com covers
all of the new APIs that
are on web browsers
and web technologies.
So it's not just Chrome, but it
covers Chrome, Safari, Internet
Explorer, Opera, et cetera.
Now what you can see
here is a whole lot
of different features,
and you can actually
click on each of them and
have a look at the status,
and there's color-coding.
If you would like to understand
the guide to the color-coding
and the browsers, just click
this little question mark.
It brings you up a whole guide
of what the color-codings mean,
the various browser
maturity levels, which
browser support,
which API, et cetera,
and this makes your
development life easier.
What's interesting is
this entire dashboard here
that you're seeing for Chrome
status is built with Polymer.
Polymer is a fantastic
new UI toolkit
being built for the web, and
the talk right after mine
will talk all about Polymer.
So keep that in mind when you
play with this and explore it.
Today we're going to be covering
mature features and immature
features.
So I'd just like to
show you that if you
have a phone-- a real
phone, like this phone
here-- if you go to Chrome
and you type in-- well
I can't quite read
that-- "chrome flags."
In there you can see lots of
different experimental features
you can enable in
Chrome for Android.
So if you choose to use those
experimental features that
aren't quite mature
yet, then all
you do is turn on
Chrome flags, turn
on the experimental feature,
try it out, build sites,
prepare for the future.
The difference between a
desktop web application
and a mobile web application
is the size of the screen.
That's the main
difference in criteria.
This makes
development difficult.
Who has difficulty developing
for mobile devices?
A few people over here.
I'm sure everybody does.
I'd just like to cover
a few things that
are very important when
developing mobile web
applications.
One is this viewport meta tag.
Now when you're
developing a desktop site,
normally you specify a
very wide content width.
You may specify 1,000 pixels
is the width of your content.
The browser on the phone doesn't
look any different to the web
server.
So when you serve the
content, it shrinks,
and the text is
completely unreadable.
If you use the meta tag
using the viewport attribute,
the viewport meta
tag, you can actually
define the size of the contents,
so that the mobile browser can
make intelligent
decisions on how
to scale the content so your
users can actually read it.
I won't go into too much
detail about how to use this,
but this is very mature.
It's in all mobile browsers,
and there's a nice demonstration
here at this URL at the
bottom that you can look at.
OK, device adaptation--
this is coming very soon.
What this does is leverage a CSS
to do the viewport adaptation.
So the meta tag is
old-style, the new style
will be controlled by CSS.
This is much more versatile.
And this is already in
Chrome and Internet Explorer
mobile, so keep an eye
on this for the future.
Today we already
have media queries.
Has anybody in the room
used media queries?
Put your hand up.
Yes, people have used
media queries, excellent.
Media queries are
a really great way
to change the content
on your mobile site
depending on the device
that is reading it.
So it's very easy to
develop a desktop site that
will look great on mobile
by leveraging media queries.
Now, this is another
very nice media query.
You can actually detect the
orientation of the device.
As you can see here, when
we change the orientation
of our phone, the content
actually rotates and changes
in response to the orientation
we have of the phone.
So when I grab my device,
if I grab it, and I flip it,
you actually get a
different visual appearance.
It's also in every
mobile browser,
so you should be using
it if you need it.
Another very
interesting new feature
that is here in all browsers
on mobile are viewpoint units.
People who are used
to positioning content
on their screen using
percentages-- that's
percentage of the
containing block
or percentage of
the whole page--
if you use viewpoint
units, these
are percentages of your
actual screen real estate.
So here, 30vh is 30% of
the height of the viewport.
So you can choose the
height of the viewport,
the width of the viewport,
the minimum dimension
of the viewport or the maximum
dimension of the viewport.
Another fantastic new
module in CSS3 is Flexbox.
CSS3 Flexbox,
flexible box module
lets you separate your
content from your layout.
The beauty of this is
that your HTML content can
be logical in order so
your story is semantically
unchanged, but when you put
it on different devices,
you can change the
layout completely.
You can swap order,
swap location,
independent of the
original HTML content.
So this is a very, very
good way to change,
if you have a desktop
site, for example.
With navigation at
the top, content
in the middle, extra
content at the bottom,
when you shrink to
a smaller device,
you can move the navigation
or move the stuff
at the top down to the bottom
and have the center content
as the first thing that
your mobile user reads.
All right, now here is a
very interesting new feature
which is coming now.
It's already in
Chrome and Opera.
This is position: sticky.
Now when you do a CSS layout
with fixed positioning,
you can anchor something to
the screen in a set location.
This lets the user scroll
the content around and have
something that is static,
but that's very limited.
With the sticky positioning,
you can actually
associate one piece of content
to another block of content.
And as you see here,
the capital letters
are anchored to the
content within them.
So as we scroll, you can see
that the sticky content sticks
to the top of the screen
and then scrolls off.
This lets you build UIs that
are very similar to native UIs,
just using web technologies.
So this is a very
nice feature that's
coming to mobile browsers.
All right, this is a
great looking man here,
who is featured in all of my
slides, who is showing you here
the full screen API.
If you're trying to build
immersive HTML5 games,
you need to be able to
take over the entire screen
real estate on the browser.
This used to be done using
window.scroll 2.01, which
was a bit of a hack.
That is no longer the
correct way to do this.
There is now a
proper JavaScript API
which lets you do full screen.
Now when full screen is
enabled, the only way
to enable full screen
is by user interaction,
so your user has to
tap or click or perform
some kind of interaction to
actually create the full screen
experience.
So JavaScript can't suddenly
pop up and take over the screen
and look like
another application.
I'll demonstrate that shortly.
So everybody's walking
around with phones.
Who has a smartphone?
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX DANILO: Oh, come
on, this is Korea,
everybody has a smartphone.
All right, you're walking
around, so what can you do?
How do you build a better
experience for your developers
when you're walking
around with a smartphone?
What you need is to take
advantage of the fact
that the phone is
in your pocket.
So the way you do that is
provide services and web
applications that take advantage
of what the browser knows.
Now the browser
knows where you are,
and that's really,
really useful.
For example, if you've
got a mapping application,
you can actually use the
browser to say I am here
and get the correct map
for where you're standing.
Or if your application is
searching for restaurants,
you can use the geolocation
to search restaurants
within the local area.
Now this is a very, very easy
API to use, as you can see.
You can just get the
latitude and the longitude.
In fact, you can set a listener.
This bottom little
piece of code here
lets you have a
JavaScript listener that
listens to changes in position,
so you can dynamically
update your location.
So it's easy to build something
like a tracking application
for when you're
riding a bicycle.
It shows you where you
are, and as you ride,
you move on the map.
And this is in every
mobile browser today,
so you should use this.
Now here's another one
that's very interesting.
Because these devices have
accelerometers and gyroscopes,
when you move them
around, the browser
can actually detect
that motion, and you
can use device orientation to
build all sorts of experiences.
So I'll just show
you a little example.
So here is my Chrome browser.
Now as I said before, we
have the full screen API,
which takes care
of the full screen.
We have device orientation.
So if I tap the Start button,
it goes into full screen,
and we have this
full-screen experience.
And if you'll see, there's
a little Chrome ball
that rolls around, and so this
is using device orientation
to basically play
a little ball game.
So we can roll around,
little Chrome rolls around.
We actually have a full-screen
HTML5 game here using
device orientation to
run the ball around
and hopefully score more points.
These are real APIs you
can use for HTML5 gaming.
We have a session
later on in the day
which does a deep dive
into HTML5 gaming.
And the fact that we have
these device accesses,
and we have the full-screen,
you can actually
build powerful HTML5 games
in modern browsers on devices
today.
Another interesting
thing that you
can have that is now in
browsers is the ability
to detect if you're
connected to the network.
There are JavaScript
events which tell you
if you are connected
to the network
or if you're
disconnected, so you
can make intelligent
choices about what
to do when the user is offline.
So if you put your browser or
your phone into airplane mode,
you know immediately that
you can't get the network
so that you can make
smart choices about what
you present to the user.
So when you reconnect to the
network you will get an event.
When that event hits, you could
do something like synchronize
to your server or
things like that,
so these are important
ones to know about.
It is also important
to understand
the online-offline status is
just connection to the network.
It doesn't mean you can
get to your web server.
Now storage APIs are a very
interesting picture today
on mobile browsers.
There's a lot of variation
between the browsers.
We have local
storage everywhere,
but local storage is restricted
to very simple storage,
small amounts of data.
There is no query
or lookup, so it's
pretty stupid, or pretty
simple, I should say.
We have these two
other storage mediums.
We have WebSQL and IndexedDB.
Now WebSQL was an old standard
that is now deprecated.
So we encourage people
to give up on WebSQL
because it's going away.
It's no longer
being standardized,
but it is in a lot of
mobile browsers today.
IndexedDB is also in a number
of mobile browsers today.
It is much more recent.
It's also the standard that is
going to be used going forward,
so we would recommend,
as a mobile developer,
you look at IndexedDB,
learn the APIs.
And of course, you can see
the feature table here,
how IndexedDB is not supported
on the Android browser
or on Safari for mobile, so
the simple solution to that
is to use abstraction library.
So here are three
abstraction libraries.
They hide all the detail
of the implementation
from the developer.
So you as a developer,
you can just
write, using one of these
abstraction libraries.
If the browser
supports IndexedDB,
it will work straight
to IndexedDB.
if the browser doesn't support
IndexedDB and supports WebSQL,
it would perform the
translation for you,
so this is the easy way to
solve mass storage on the phone.
All right, now here's
an interesting aspect
of phones-- who here
has written a book?
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX DANILO: Ah, we have a few
book authors, here, excellent.
At the back, excellent.
How many of you wrote
that book on your phone?
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX DANILO: Nobody.
That's funny, I always
write books on my phone.
Nobody writes books on phones.
In fact, it's a horrible
experience typing on a phone.
It's slow, it's painful, and
the users of your applications
don't like typing just
as much as you do.
So when you design your web
applications and your websites,
you should use
semantic input types.
So here you can see, there
are many different input types
that you can apply
to your content.
So just take the first one,
for example-- input type
equals email.
When you specify type
equals email on your phone,
the keyboard that's presented
to the user has the @ sign.
If you see down the bottom
left, there's the symbol for @,
so it's a keyboard tailored
to typing in email addresses.
Same thing for search, you get
a nice little magnifying glass
to search.
Telephone numbers, brings
up the phone keyboard
for phone number
entry, et cetera.
So these semantic
types do one thing.
And the one thing is
they save your user time.
Your user doesn't have
to fumble around finding
the right keyboard,
switching modes,
the browser does
the work for you.
So if you have a look
at the date types--
the date types bring your
little spinning things
for days and months.
What do we have here-- we have
a search one with the magnifying
glass.
It's a beautiful video,
this-- the phone one.
Now if we have a look at the
number one which is next,
the interesting thing about this
is with the number input type,
you can specify a number range.
I can say, range
from 100 to 200,
and the browser will do the
checking that it's valid.
All right now here's another
very interesting feature
of phones today-- all
phones are touch phones,
or all phones that matter.
The thing about touch
phones is that touch phones
are fairly new.
Browsers were developed in the
days of mouses and keyboards,
and so the events
that come in for touch
are really tailored
for an era beforehand,
a long time ago when
everyone used a mouse.
Because of that there is
a 300 millisecond delay
if you tap on a link in the
browser before the actual link
gets activated.
Now that's a huge
problem with development,
and later on in the
day we will show you
how to fix that-- in fact,
Jake will, wherever Jake is.
So keep that in mind.
But there are a number
of demos with this,
and the thing that's interesting
with the touch events
is that you can detect
movement and touch,
and you get a lot of events, and
they're very, very inaccurate.
So when you touch,
it's much less accurate
than using a mouse.
In fact, quite often the
touch start and touch end
will be at different positions
even though you haven't moved
your finger, so
keep that in mind.
Now everybody realizes that
touch events and mouse events,
being from different
backgrounds have problems.
So Microsoft made
a proposal to W3C
for a thing called
pointer events.
Pointer events unify mouse
events and touch events.
So what they do is they
provide a common framework
for both mouse and
touch, and it's
a very, very nicely distilled
kind of a combination of both.
Of course, the problem
with pointer events
is only one browser
supports them.
People have been
building JavaScript shims
to actually simulate
pointer events,
and there is a lot of activity
to bring pointer events
to other browsers.
But it is one to keep
in mind for the future.
All right, so we'll
get on to what
is different about a
phone and a computer.
So what's nice about the phone?
Can anybody suggest anything?
All right, I'll suggest it.
How about we have a camera?
We've got a camera in the
phone so I can take photos.
Now look at that.
As we said before,
we have input types,
and we have the
semantic types where
we set telephone and
email search, et cetera.
If we actually play with
the input type and tell it
we want to take a
photo, the browser
will detect the
camera in the phone,
and when you
activate that input,
it will actually go
directly to the camera.
Now if I had no
camera in my phone,
it would go to my
media gallery and let
me browse a photo out
of my media gallery.
So the media
capture in the phone
lets you actually grab photos,
use the camera from your web
application.
This is a very,
very powerful thing.
You could use it for
instagram-style sites,
for example.
Another feature, which is coming
along, is called Web Audio.
Web Audio is a very powerful
audio signal generator.
This lets you create
notes, synthesize things,
do all sorts of fancy effects.
It's very new.
It's in Chrome,
Safari, and Opera.
But it only runs on
high-end devices, so
devices that support
the NEON ARM extension.
So NEON is like a separate CPU
core specifically for signal
processing, and all
modern smartphones
have the NEON extensions.
So this is coming, and it will
become really, really popular,
especially for games.
Now another interesting thing,
which is really, really good
is getUserMedia.
getUserMedia lets
you grab your camera
and then use it on your
phone from JavaScript.
So what this does is you place
a video element on your page,
you say, "getUserMedia," which
gives you a JavaScript object,
you attach the JavaScript
object to your video element,
and that lets you play video
directly on your web page,
coming from your camera.
Now you can do all sorts of
things like grab still frames.
So if you connect that
video to a canvas element,
you can grab frames
out of the video.
So you can do all
sorts of amazing things
with getUserMedia.
But of course, it will
ask the user permission
for using the camera first.
Now who's heard of WebRTC?
A few people.
Web real time communication--
this is possibly
one of the biggest new
technologies in web
and mobile web to
come in recent times.
WebRTC allows true peer
to peer connection,
so you can transmit audio
and video peer to peer.
But one of the best
features of this,
which is not well understood,
is the RTC data channel.
Now you can send
video, audio, and data.
So you can send game data or
files or anything you'd like.
The beauty of the
data channel is
it has very, very low latency.
It has guaranteed 100
milliseconds latency.
So for multi-player
gaming you can use WebRTC,
use the data channel to have
fast update of your game play.
There are many applications,
and we probably can't even
imagine most of the
applications for this.
But there are a number
of examples of it,
and so you should try it.
It's in Chrome.
It's in Firefox.
It's in Opera.
And so combined with
all those browsers,
there are probably over a
billion WebRTC-enabled clients
out in the world today, so
keep an eye on this one.
Of course, we all love games.
And who can't love WebGL.
WebGL is available
from Chrome 30 onwards.
It's out there.
It's limited on mobile, but it
is there, and it does perform.
So here's a random
example that Paul
found somewhere
of somebody doing
an interesting thing in WebGL.
WebGL lets you access the GPU
on the phone, on the device,
and do high-speed fully
accelerated graphics, something
you should definitely experiment
with if you like playing games
or you like fancy 3D.
This is a new feature--
Add to Homescreen.
Who runs web applications as
an icon on their phone today?
Not too many people.
Now the reason for that is it's
always been a bit difficult.
I'll just give you another
quick little demo, here.
So here we have Chrome again.
I found this nice web page.
This is a really cool web page.
It tells me what
the forecast is.
It tells me the forecast here.
It uses geolocation,
so it knows where I am.
It pulls up the
current forecast,
and I really would like
to use that every day.
So if I just select my menu
and press Enter Homescreen down
here and give it a
name, then lo and behold
it appears on my homescreen.
Look at that.
So now we have an icon that
is an actual web application.
If I find try and start it,
it starts as a full-screen web
application.
So now we have fully
installable web apps
as first class citizens
on Android through Chrome.
Add to homescreen is very new.
It's in Chrome 30.
It will be in Chrome stable very
soon, but the beauty of this
is that the application
will start full screen,
so they look like a
native application.
They have an icon.
You can select the icon, and it
means if you're an HTML5 game
developer, for example, you can
build a full-screen application
that uses the device,
uses the camera,
looks like a complete
native application
and runs beautifully.
You can even leverage WebGL
if you need high performance
graphics.
Another feature
of mobile browsers
that most people
wouldn't know about
is the use of Android Intents.
So when you have URLs,
you can specify the target
that you're trying to hit.
So normally you
jump to a website
or you jump to something
else, but you can actually
specify intent.
So you see here, we have set an
intent of a bar code scanner.
So that markup in your
web page tells the browser
I actually want to use whatever
application scans bar codes.
So in this case, we've
actually set up the intent
to say, scan, et
cetera-- you can
look at the example
at home-- but it
tells Android to go off and
find the proper application
to handle my request.
This is all done
through the intent URL.
And this is available
today, of course.
Now this is going to be the
subject of a number of talks
today-- performance matters.
Everything is slower.
When we look at this-- I'll just
talk about this in a moment--
the speed of a mobile phone
today is approximately 1/10
of your desktop machine.
The speed is not just the CPU.
The speed is memory
bandwidth, the CPU,
the high resolution
screens we have today.
We have full HD
mobile phones today.
But the network is probably
one of the biggest pain points.
Network connectivity
into 2G and 3G networks
has very, very high latency.
Once 4G becomes common, then
that will be greatly improved,
but for now the network is
one of the slowest components
in getting a web page from
your server to your client.
Now today we have this
navigation-timing API.
If you have a look at the
typical loading of a web page,
if you choose a URL and
wait for it to show,
there are all these times.
There's the network
time, there's
the load time from
the server, then
there's processing
before I see anything.
Now this is a big black
box-- very, very hard
to understand what is happening.
So now we have this
navigation-timing API.
This API breaks
down all the steps
in the loading of your web page.
You can see your DNS lookup.
You can see your cache loading.
You can see establishment
of a TCP connection.
You can see all the
other content loading.
You can see the
events happening.
This breaks down
your website loading,
so that you can understand
where you need to improve it.
So if all the time is
spent in server delay,
you will see it using this API.
Of course, when you
load a modern web page,
there's a lot more content
than just the one web page.
You have images, CSS
files, JavaScript files.
To understand the loading
of all the resources
that make your web
application work,
you can use the
Resource Timing API.
The Resource Timing
API will actually
show you detail for all of
the resources you're loading.
So if for example, a CSS file
is blocking the load of your web
application, you can identify it
using the Resources Timing API.
It's very, very
useful information,
especially for mobile.
The new mobile web that
we've all been developing for
is pretty awesome.
It's very exciting
to be part of this,
especially in South
Korea, because this
is the powerhouse
of smartphones.
But the thing is, what
we can do now on a phone,
which we couldn't do before--
we can adapt to screen sizes.
We can use viewport,
media queries.
We can change our content
depending on the device,
depending on the
orientation, very useful.
We can also handle
people on the move.
So we can use geolocation.
We can use device motion.
We can actually make the
web applications smarter,
respond to what
we're actually doing,
because we're not
sitting at a desk.
We can really speed our input.
The semantic types
for input make
your lives much, much simpler.
The users will love you if you
use the right semantic input
types, because it
means less typing.
The faster they get
input, the faster they
buy things from your website
or the happier they are.
The other thing that
I'm just showing you
that is really,
really amazing is
integration with
features on the device.
You have the camera.
You have accelerometers.
You can grab the microphone.
You can do all
sorts of things that
are like native
applications but work
straight out of your
browser, straight
from your web application.
The other thing that is
really important to do
is to measure performance
across all devices,
and we have a number of
methods of doing that.
We have new navigation APIs,
and the Resource Timing APIs,
which give you more information.
Later on today there will
be a number of deep dives
into how you can measure
graphics performance,
et cetera, which
all help you build
a beautiful site
that users will love.
And all this means
is more users.
Of course very, very
soon you should really
look at all these new features.
WebRTC, I highly recommend
people explore WebRTC.
It will be a huge,
huge thing on the Web.
Web Audio, especially
if you want
to do gaming or any
sound applications.
It's a fantastic API.
And of course, WebGL, which is
very exciting that it's finally
getting mobile browsers.
So that's pretty much a
very, very quick overview
of all the new APIs that are
in mobile browsers today.
Feel free to come and ask
questions whenever you like.
I'll be around
all day, so if you
have any specific questions,
please come and ask.
We have a question now.
Yes?
Yes, you.
AUDIENCE: So you have said that
current schedule [INAUDIBLE]
what example that you said
is about the [INAUDIBLE].
My question simply
is that for example,
in Android, the case of
[INAUDIBLE] having the Google
I/Os.
Google already has announced
[INAUDIBLE] the location,
and they take pictures.
So what is the difference
about the Chrome approach
and in the Google Android?
Is the Google Android's
make use of API approach?
Maybe Chrome,
itself, has supported
some of the same features that
is announced in the Google I/O
2000 TCUs?
They're reputedly
very fantastic,
but I'm wondering about
the Chrome assembly,
if it was supported [INAUDIBLE].
ALEX DANILO: The question
was that this year's I/O
Android-announced
enhanced location features
for finding the location on
the phone from an application
and whether or not the
browsers support that
and what the difference is.
What was announced was actually
the Google Play services
has an enhanced
location capability.
And what it does is it leverages
the accelerometers and motion
sensors in the
phone on top of GPS.
So traditionally the location
has been derived from GPS data,
the enhanced Android
location uses motion,
uses the device motion
sensors and accelerometers
to get a more accurate picture
of the motion of the user.
So it supplements GPS so it
creates additional accuracy
by virtue of the
phone's sensors.
Those APIs are used
by Chrome internally,
so the Android
platform improvements
filter down into the browser.
So when you use
geolocation in Chrome,
it is going through
the Android API.
Improvements to the
Android platform
automatically filter
down to the browser.
OK.
Oh, sorry?
AUDIENCE: According
to your presentation,
you provide [INAUDIBLE]
features normally,
[INAUDIBLE] return
to Chrome, not
in the Android previous
[INAUDIBLE] browsers.
So the Google [INAUDIBLE] not
on the Android, but [INAUDIBLE].
ALEX DANILO: Why don't we
take that question afterwards.
Why don't you come
and talk to me
after the talk, because it's
a little bit too detailed
for this high level-- All
right, another question, yes?
AUDIENCE: You explained several
ways to adapt to a screen size
at the web application
or web page level,
but another way that you
can adapt to the screen size
is at the http server.
You use the user agent string
and serve mobile version
or desktop version or whatever.
So what do you think
about this approach?
Do you think that this approach
should be wrong in the future
or should be improved or--
ALEX DANILO: OK, the
question is about detecting
different screen
sizes and adapting
content to the different
screen sizes versus desktop,
whether or not to
use the features
in the browser versus
using the user agent
string from the server side.
We would now highly
recommend you
don't look at the
user agent string
and do all the content
authoring responsive,
so that you adapt
to screen sizes
inside the browser
inside your content.
The reason is that the user
agent string is incredibly
unreliable, and it's
very easy for a user
to change the user agent string
so that you don't actually
know the browser properly.
So it's a very, very unreliable
way to detect the user agent.
So media queries and all of
the other adaptive designs
is really what we'd
recommend today.
OK, all right on that
I'll say thank you.
Anybody want to come-- oh,
one last question, yes?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
My question is concerning
to your homescreen feature.
So Apple already
supports Apple meta tag.
I think that the homescreen
feature of Chrome
is very similar with that,
so using the meta tag anyway.
But I think that anyway that
could be a fragmentation
because there are no
standard code aps yet, right?
So as far as I know, in the
[INAUDIBLE] or web application
tools, they tried to
make many faster formats
for web applications that
is added by a [INAUDIBLE],
so my question is that
Chrome [INAUDIBLE]
has a plan to support that
kind of standard features
for installation of
web applications.
ALEX DANILO: OK, The question is
about the install to homescreen
feature, because
at the moment it's
a meta tag that's Apple-specific
and whether or not
this is being
standardized and we're
going on with the
standardization
of this feature.
Well now in Chrome we
support the meta tags
that indicate to an Apple
device that we recognize
the Apple-specific meta
tags to enable an install
to homescreen for
backward compatibility.
We intend to go forward with
the standardization process.
We actually mention Mozilla as
far as install to homescreen.
The Co-chair of the
web apps working group
who used to work for Mozilla
now works for Google in Sydney
as of about two weeks ago.
So we are very active in making
sure that we push forward
through standardization,
because we really
believe in open standards
and W3C and all that.
So we will definitely
be following that path
to standardization.
OK, all right everybody,
thanks very much for listening
and enjoy the rest of the day.
[APPLAUSE]